okay oh you're gonna love this I could
tell
are you ready yeah alright ladies and
gentlemen welcome to your favorite
podcast you know today okay Neal Brennan
this is just singing mic and I always
offer the singer bite to the guest
no thank you okay no singing mic for you
thank you my other dual out yeah it
turned you down give me a little take a
little something off good good all right
yep
anyways ladies and gentlemen I can still
hear you okay ladies gentle to the
podcast mr. Neal come on into the frame
buddy I'm not in frame now there we go
consummate director oh yeah somebody
asked you Neal is directing my pocket I
love it great
you looked huge I look tiny look a mess
if you look like you've captured me I
did I captured you for my pocket not
some truth to that
I'd also like to say I have a couple
things I want to get off my chest go
it's always it's always a it's always a
problem when you realize someone's
podcast is at their house right you're
like well maybe it's at a bit of office
building then you get then you're like
this [ __ ] gonna make me smell
this soup I know and then you weren't
wearing socks which is like dude but
that's your thing
no that's a thing I don't think people
should in when they're dealing with
other people man their feet should every
man's feet should absolutely never be
out so you
ever go to the beach uh or put really
you don't go to any pool parties not
really like that I mean I'll go but I
don't take my feet up again we're not at
the pool river my point but I'm just
saying you said if he should never be
yes they should never bury I mean if you
gotta wear it if you got to go to the
beach the pool fine but take them all
out at the last second I want your shoes
next to the pool like a [ __ ] Japanese
restaurant that's what I want you know I
just went to a sushi restaurant the
other day in like Marina del Rey and you
had to what do you call it take your
shoes off so I was immediately like I
don't like this see and then I know but
then not only that you had to sit on the
ground yeah and you need to put your
legs in sight like a like like a holes
in our sin it's called onsen eating so
you're not a culture what's gonna happen
into the hole it's system [ __ ] the
way it was like okay this is fine but
like I'm a big ass dude so like I have
to like you know maneuver myself we all
got a maneuver it's not easier for you
you're like a when he ordered but when I
didn't know what I walked in as soon as
I walked in and they say take your shoes
off at a restaurant in front of
strangers I'm like I should have been
like let's go I got my girlfriend was
like oh this seems like a good thing and
so we like you know we did it but
actually the food was great but it was
but it was just like you know I don't
know when you when you go to a sushi
restaurant in a strip mall it's hard to
feel like you're you're all this is like
the greatest shoes you see experience
but you know well that there's that
place in the valley that's like the most
the best in Atlanta it's in strip mall
apparel right well this is just what I'm
saying about this I want you to remember
about LA yeah but that's the ever been
in Japan it's there in like the ninth
floor that's what I said I haven't been
during the subway right right literally
that my favorite vegan place in Japan is
in its own way
Wow yeah I mean it's like it looks like
a mall but it's still the train station
yeah yeah yeah that's right who deals
also vegan have you been vegan for your
whole life
ten years yeah and never going back
no as a matter of fact right now I'm
doing a fast so yeah extra irritable
oh you think even more you'd what you
wouldn't know it
she wouldn't know part but this is kind
of my normal irritability under the
derrick yes you're I had a two tacos
yesterday around lunch and then I wanted
to do a 24-hour fast but I had a banana
at like 9:00 p.m. and I haven't had
anything since dude so you believe that
the fasts work yet the I looked I did I
got a call in Oscar P couple weeks ago
and I did the fast for that and I kind
of liked it like I like I felt good yeah
yeah and so I did I just googled it and
it seemed all of the if done correctly
it seems like this sec after 24 hours
like really good [ __ ] happens for your
body now do you think that you know when
you weren't eating some of that vegan
food it had nothing to do with it at all
either you think like like that you you
got you weren't eating anything and
maybe some of that vegan foods not that
good for you did you think it had that
had anything to do with it too or just
too fast I'm saying like because I got
four I'm just three so I'm saying this
is because I made a deal with my girl
stop eating bread so I haven't been
eatin bread for like a week mm-hm and
immediately I was like oh [ __ ] our
breads skinny why you getting skinny
bread is [ __ ] useless it's it's
delicious and [ __ ] but like and
nutritionally it's a it's about as bad I
think yeah it's um spoonful of sugar
like literally just like gulp it's
useless for you but your body hates it
so yeah you could lose all the weight
you lost once you could lose again yeah
I'm sure I don't know how old you are
but like when you're like I'm late 40s
and it's like is so hard I gained way so
easily I've find my appetite is less
than it like it you know you know you
hit that you always hear like that I
remember my mom you should just like not
eat dinner and I'd be like why don't you
eat she's like I've been
picking all day and now I know exactly
what she means like it doesn't take that
much for me to feel full so Phil oh okay
so I've stopped it's a it's I hate it I
hate not being able to eat as much so
you see like eating's great fun of [ __ ]
it's delicious
you fed you've done let's get a dig
counter going yeah you bet you've eaten
before so you but but you ultimately the
older you get the less you need to eat
less food you need that's why you know I
got on one of those like meal plan
things just or just a food delivery
service just because I like to portion
control of it yeah my problem is if this
in front of me I'll eat elite at all
yeah well that's you know what's
interesting someone who's never been
anywhere nice that's you where my
flights going what the [ __ ] kind of
racket are you people running a strip
mall what I beg honey check my wallet at
nice restaurants like you know $40 an
entree restaurant not big portions yeah
i this is i say this all the time too is
like when you go to a really nice
steakhouse you spending a lot of money
and you don't feel just like you know
like you had a gordito to do cuz you get
you get spinach if you get so money get
the spinach you're gonna get the sides
of mashed potatoes
keep going getting a green bean I'm
beating the cream cord and the creamed
corn and I don't need to tell you the
baked potato
hey we should get dessert right I'm not
a dessert guy I'm a huge times if I
could just eat sugar I would really I am
NOT a dessert guy I prefer actually if
I'm gonna have a dessert to have it
first the like let me just get a little
piece of cake or something first because
I don't like it just I don't want it I
just don't want it afterwards but yeah
good you know you eat what do you what's
your Blake traps just just eating too
much got it
that's really what it is and so like one
thing about like having like so with my
girlfriend I'm she doesn't eat a lot she
eats like a little bird right so then I
started to do this with her we'll go and
we'll just share stuff
and that works great because she's
eating like you know 25% right
yeah and I'm kidding I'm him he's a
smaller portion so something that I
would hate the whole thing hot the hard
thing is gonna be not it's it's you're
gonna want to give yourself permission
to order a second thing well we've been
pretty good with it this is a hard thing
man like that's why I want to ask you
like so 10 years ago when you decided to
go vegan why'd you make that choice and
how did you stay well because I had a
weird taste in my mouth that I couldn't
get rid of like I was like what the [ __ ]
is this like I didn't know if it was
like an STI I don't know what it was oh
god all the tests everything it was just
a weird it felt like I burnt my mouth oh
and it persisted for months so I was
like let me stop then I started getting
rid of things slowly I was like let me
stop eating me let me I was like I don't
really miss meat and chicken was
starting to grossed me out right just as
like also I there's a documentary that
if you watch it you'll just be vegan
I know exactly Oh see okay I'm not
completely there yet but I saw a
documentary about milk and I was out
after that I just was out I was like
okay I call me Mel you're already
there's a documentary called the
Earthlings yeah that I told someone I
was a vegan ago did you see Earthlings I
go yep and like that's the one yeah I'm
starting to see little things like
anytime I see like that those show like
a chicken and it's like you know hugging
someone or a chicken that way with the
most part is they they keep them in
these disgusting pens yeah I know Jan
they eat their own [ __ ] the whole day
yeah so people are like you like tofu
that's main alive I'm like dude the only
reason your chicken is alive because of
all the garbage they pump it like all
the steroids and hormones and they pump
it with like bleach I mean just the
worst [ __ ] yeah that's why it's not that
it's no longer
it hasn't been natural in 40 years
that's why so you think that's even like
a fancy steakhouse same sort of thing
where they I mean they could make yes
he'll be the Marsh Marsh Berry Farms or
whatever yet
yes fine but I don't but even then I'm
like it so people go I've tried this
joke and it never worked but it's like
people go it's a free range so and it's
like that's it going yeah well you know
we gave this guy the death penalty but
before we did
he had cable like we let him roam around
you still killed we had really good
Wi-Fi yeah I see what you mean love
animal I like animals but I'm not one of
these like Whitney where it's like I'm
just down you're threading a horse so I
don't I don't I like them but I think I
put humans above I'm with you on this
I've been talking about this on stage
actually I just I I'm glad that there
are first of all people that like
animals
a lot of times these are people that
don't have problems with bills they
don't got human problem that's a good
indicator you know I mean so they're
like first they either upper middle
class or they're rich they're mostly why
you know yeah and thankfully there if
you're in the animals and you don't
visibly look poor you're rich if I can't
tell you're bored
yeah because you've like if your hair if
your hair is not matted and you're not
wearing a fleece and like dirty Blake
farm clothes you're rich yeah because
it's because these elective it's purely
a life and they walk out of Petsmart
with your three-legged dog and they step
over homeless people you know acting
like no you cuz I've seen you do that
joke and that's a joke I've tried and it
never works works great
I know I've saw it work and I was like
it's not it's something about you like
you know you got like a certain smugness
about you yeah that is it's not as
lovable as I am I don't I mean but no so
that is so so you know if you want to go
like personality for personality though
I'm that's a much better person yeah I
am so nice to people you would
when I die they're gonna go Gino Neil
used to blank and you're gonna what
no I know first of all one I believe
that - I just think you're aloof Julie
you just aloof I think you're just a
private dude yeah I never I don't sit
but but I just I just think that my
mom's comment personality right people
can't read but even a bunch of comic
personalities you talk to me for a
minute and I'm warm and remember
[ __ ] and I never I never defy Oaks
and [ __ ] but uh that's like the thing I
just did that Dave the Dave Twain thing
just aired the Chappelle Twain thing and
so it's like doing well on YouTube
because I'd [ __ ] ripped yeah boy like
oh like why would Dave Chappelle wanna
work with somebody who's not funny like
what did you think was happening yeah
they did but they don't know no you said
not so much seems more fun than you he's
way more fun than me does that put like
a little chip on your shoulder a little
chip after another cheer for it right a
little chip I have a I am all chip no
shoulder that's me the name of your book
is second shoulder put in to support my
chip
yeah it's [ __ ] huge yeah but that was
the fight I knew people thought that I
knew people say it all the time like in
in on Twitter and all that [ __ ] and it's
like okay all right yep and then here's
another where the people like okay
here's another yeah but today okay
you're right he's a [ __ ] who he's a
visibly dumb person who would hire a
lackey that is right but being funny and
a great stand-up great writer
venomoth has is it like are you saying
do you feel that people don't think
you're good at what you do
yeah okay yes I think people just have a
bias because they think I'm Dave's buddy
so they just but you like being Dave's
buddy you you I mean like you bel show
yeah I like that what we did yeah yeah
yeah I could tell that you really liked
that a lot
uh what's not to like yeah not well hey
people get
people get a job you know like and then
even and then even if it's like a great
job from the outside you go oh my god
that must be great but everybody has
issues everybody you know it doesn't
always work it's not always copacetic
every time you're loud you don't me and
you could Google me and Dave had huge
issues yeah yeah but I'm still proud of
the show right that's different from
being like I had a good time doing it oh
I'd in the speech they cut it up and I
was like it wasn't fun not fun at all
but but that's not the I'm glad I did it
yeah it wasn't fun like it's you know
but I don't think that there's any I
mean like but everyone thought that I
was like I was it when you're in a
partnership the and me and Chappelle
used to have a deal where we wouldn't
say who wrote what because I knew from
the time we wrote half-baked everyone in
showbiz was gonna think I wrote it and
everyone in comedy was gonna thing he
wrote it so I was like let's just not
let's just say we wrote it and that was
it's a good deal because I mean Dave
gets it too
ironically like he someone and I won't
I'll tell you off the air uh-huh someone
drunkenly said to him you recently all
you know his jokes Neil wrote that whole
show like the second you talk I mean
it's just rude Brian right but I get it
way more than him but he still gets it
yeah what I guess you know I guess I
don't see that only because I know you
at the consciousness oh I know you as a
comic cuz for my first experiences view
is like us doing the belly room trying
to prove to Tommy that we work on yes
you know what I mean
so like just so you know that's how I
know you yeah you know so like so I
don't I never won I didn't know that you
were a part of the Chappelle show until
I started hearing your name when you get
brought up on stage you know that was
like oh really he was a part you know
yeah I remember one time you you're
funny this is my one a funny interaction
with you we're at the Laugh Factory and
I didn't even know about half-baked at
the time and you were like yeah then you
said you said to me like yeah I've been
in a studio system for 16 years
yes so now it's 22
what I'm saying is it's like I knew you
as somebody like myself trying to make
it in this in this like stand-up comedy
game in LA but yeah I wasn't like
[ __ ] I didn't feel entitled
anything right right right
well you see by the way that I'm that
way sometimes because of from my
experience of playing sports so like
when I played sports when I play
basketball I I loved someone tell me
that I couldn't do something I love the
challenge of proving somebody wrong I
had coaches told me I wasn't good enough
and that I would come back and like you
know my high school my senior year coach
was like dogging me and I went to camp
and I came back and I was all league
when I can't you know for that year so I
so I thought I would use that same
energy will in entertainment but it
doesn't translate always so it's you
know it's just a weird weird uttal it's
to it people you can play sports
emotionally and you can use it as a fuel
yeah you can't use fuel jokes even like
I need to pay my rent yeah like I'm
gonna not like you can work hard you
know all that stuff but like they said I
couldn't do audience doesn't if you have
a funny idea can you perform it it's
like I don't only occasionally I felt
like I had that like Tommy made me feel
like that at the Comedy Store huh he
made me feel like you know it was like I
had to like constantly prove something
to this guy or like I you know I felt
passed over and stuff like that with him
but I enjoyed that energy cuz I always
felt like it brought the best out of me
you know what I mean I'm actually better
when I'm supported and like I know that
about myself like if someone's like
you're gonna do great and take as much
time as you want and I believe support I
will do the work I don't want to feel
angry right all right well I just don't
I needed to I hate I mean I'm so I'm so
like
routinely discounted that I'm used to it
but I it nothing makes me very few
things make me angry
then like after the Twain thing I got
off stage and a manager came up to me
and said would you consider producing
another show and I go so you just saw
that and said this guy should produce a
TV show that was your thought there and
it was I just screamed at him for 15
minutes because even in that moment you
still felt like what do I gotta do
right it's like well I just did better
than everybody named Allah it's a good
list of comedians and I did better than
all of them I'd they buy their own a
recollection like I did but it's so what
so even then but that's just like a
prejudice thing like if but you don't
say that that fuels you though I feel
like it fuels you not in a good way okay
I mean not in a like when I when I was
preparing for it I knew that it would be
judged the way it was someone wrote on
Instagram Arab on Twitter one of the one
of the sites that they go oh I for 20
years I've wondered what Neil could have
possibly written on Chappelle's Show and
now I can think of 60 things which is
like thank you sir thank you I'm gonna
venmo you $100 cuz that's all I've ever
[ __ ] won
it's just credit just the credit that I
deserve I'm not asking for anything I
didn't do like I'm not saying like I'm
not saying I came up with [ __ ] The
Daily Show I just came with what's your
pelvic that's all that's all I did yeah
yeah but because when you're partners
with someone who is that demonstrably
talented they people can't get their
head around they they also want to
dismiss one of you they don't want to
feel bad about two people being more
talented than them so they go he's a god
and he's a [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] and
they do that with all partners but I
feel that I feel from you that you are
you are very proud of the Chappelle show
why shouldn't have it yeah of course I'm
not saying you shouldn't be but I mean
I'm just saying like so like but with
that being proud of it you you you would
like you say you would also appreciate
people being like hey great job Neil on
what you did for the during the
Chappelle show
yeah just occasionally
be nice of people just I just said I
mean I guess but I get like but which
I'm not I've never been mad at that it's
when people go I mean just look at the
comments on any of my clips any it's
like the first thing they bring up is
this guy always brings Dave Chappelle
okay yeah I well I did this thing with
him yeah we did a you love yes we did a
heist together I figured you might want
to hear about it yeah or whatever so so
but I'm happy to talk about whatever
yeah not feeling but but that's the I
don't know how we got on this but um but
it's just about like you know how like
you like you say you you shine more when
you get like praise once you get yeah
stuff just like we all are like that
yeah and I and I'm what you you actually
it's something I want to bring up is
like you actually like hit me to
something that would that was very
helpful to me that I that I still use
and I'm gonna put the picture up for the
failures cognitive behavior yeah they're
probably behave cognitive cognitive
behavioral therapy and I still have it
in my favorites so it's like the top one
is thought to create feelings so this is
don't have any explain what so therapy
is a type of therapy that's very
effective but one of the downsides of
the therapy industry is they don't tell
when you go see just a regular talk
therapist they don't go hey just so you
know there's a lot of different theories
out here and don't marry yourself to
this one cuz you might be more helped by
blank it would be like a car dealership
telling it would be like a Volvo
dealership telling you about
BMW they're never gonna do it but
because someone's mental health is on
the line they really [ __ ] [ __ ] right
the so cognitive behavioral therapy is
something I found when I just googled
negative thought patterns and cognitive
behavioral therapy gives you a list of
the most common negative thought
patterns and there's like ten of them
and I actually don't like the chart you
use there's one that's more there's more
detail yeah that too
dissing styles but this one really helps
just to like remember like hey you know
stop thinking it negative because this
is gonna make you to feel negative you
know feelings and you start negative
actions yeah the food's going yeah yeah
the it's the old Fat Bastard monologue I
eat because I'm sad or I might sad
because I eat Thank You Fat Bastard that
was fat bastard was he something you
call someone in a movie 20 years ago now
you just say calorically challenge that
doesn't know their fall Gottesman the
okay so so it's just it get so whenever
you think those thoughts you will
immediately say oh throw it away throw
it away that's a nonsense thought that's
a all-or-nothing thinking everyone does
blank I always [ __ ] up I'm bat no you
made a mistake in this one instance or
if something goes your way you minimize
it like well which the only do good good
like or if something you catastrophize
things yes I just did the worst podcast
like now it just makes you aware of
those thoughts and helps you dispose of
them quicker yeah it was like because a
good example of that for me is like oh
so I'm at the Comedy Store one night and
I'm much go up in the main room I talked
about this on another episode it doesn't
matter I don't even know if it came out
yet but so Adam comes up to me he says
right before I go on right before I'm
gonna go to the green room in their
bedroom he goes hey Erica do your a
stuff tonight okay
my first thought is like you don't tell
me what my sleep all mushy today you
know I'm just like my head I'm in the
I'm in the green room I'm [ __ ] pacing
because I'm mad I'm mad I'm like what a
[ __ ] would he say that to me cuz that's
my first thought it's gotta be something
negative I get offstage I did my I did I
picked a set where I was like I know
this is a crusher okay so then I he
comes watch me go so I learned to say no
Jay go so you know the difference would
between your normal set and your crusher
set well you do we all do yeah and and
Adam knows you do so don't work on
somebody to nos have been there or they
must have been filming or something see
that's your first thought that's
interesting too as a producer because
there's things that I wouldn't say that
somebody
unless there was a reason right and if
forget obviously there was because when
I got off stage he came up to me he was
like oh man I was perfect
Ted was here you know and he's talking
about syringe so Randall's from Netflix
and even in my mind I'm like who cares
what Ted Danson thinks you know but
afterwards after that experience I said
to myself oh I gotta take them be I
gotta stop I gotta take a beat and be
like why is this person saying this to
me is that let's not take everything
negative yeah unless like fit you know
let let's just have a better experience
but still though I still thrive in those
moments because what the says I did that
energy was driving my set and I was
giving it you know what I mean and so
it's just like like when Jim Carrey's it
in the crowd you know one night it Adam
says hey Jim Carrey's here my first
thought is is this new bumping me like
so I thought what's happening you know
so again I went onstage and I was like I
had just like energy I but I I got a no
you have a persecution couple I had I
got an audition the next night and then
I was on I'm dying up here three weeks
later right you know what I was saying
you have a persecution complex yes
person well explain that what do you
guys do you think that everything is a
conspiracy against you no but I know
what you saying yeah I don't I don't I
don't I don't think it's always I I just
I just it's not like that but I don't
you should focus on the things that
could go eat you could use as motivation
in a positive way or a negative way
negatively in my experience yeah
sometimes yeah and that's what I'm
saying
like you're one of these guys who talks
about the industry all the time yeah and
it's like you work a lot dude I know but
what I'm saying to you is like I was
again I used that because I cuz I told
myself I need enemies you see him saying
so like a small microcosm of that would
be the Comedy Store so like Tommy is the
industry right you know and I was like I
gotta prove to this guy that I deserve
to be here wide so like straddle a that
right no to like okay so Comedy Central
doesn't like me uh-huh this person
doesn't let you know I mean I'm like yes
so that makes me like I gotta write more
I got
prove you know that's yes what I if
that's if you're motivated if that's you
think that's a helpful frame no I don't
think it's a help yes frame that's what
I what I'm coming to find is that it's
not helpful yeah cuz I find myself like
when I'm manufacturing things I I'm I'm
losing sight of like that maybe there
there could be you know if someone
really doesn't like me I don't know
because I'm making it out like everyone
doesn't like me or something and it's
just it just doesn't it's not a good
thought process and so like I said when
you gave me that thing it wasn't one of
the first times I was like oh you know
what I gotta stop not everything's not
everyone's against me not not
everything's negative I can't think of
it like that for motivation to make
myself better because I'm looking at
other people they're not doing that I
got like you know I look what I admire
about you when you when I I know when
you're working on something and I always
admire that like because not everybody
can do it people think they can like
there's comics we know at the store they
bring like 17 notebooks on stay here
they do all this stuff and I think that
what this is gonna show that I'm doing
it like to me it's like I don't care
what you do with that you're just this
joke it's not gonna be any better than
it is I can't think of anybody you know
I mean I I know what you mean in
hypothetical but I'm talking about like
put a normal line up at the store people
but I'm saying there's certain people
that I can when I see you doing it
there's like a way you're performing
that it's like okay I am for sure trying
to make this joke the best possible
version of it that it yeah and you're
also very like you know even if I come
up to you and go hey I got something for
you you very much like okay let me hear
this cuz I want to know if this is gonna
help me or not
nobody's like that so it's like you have
a waist the dumbest thing in the world
giving people a lot of people I don't
take tags you know that's the dumbest
first of all I can't in good conscience
do that because that's why I have a
career I literally was just would give
Chapelle tags and when I was a doorman
in 1992 so that's a and B [ __ ] so I've
given this another thing I want on my
funeral I want people to line up and say
a tag I gave them just a [ __ ] line up
of comedians
that's all there and and fake your death
just for that trust whether you come out
of the coffin yeah I just my face looks
mean yeah yeah I'm a nice guy I gave
someone a mental health yeah check yeah
yeah you got it you got a resting mean
face I got a resting doofus
and so I can't so yeah I don't I I so
I'm always feel like my I do have a bit
of a not prosecutor persecution complex
with that but I do go like why does
anyone [ __ ] give me texts I give
[ __ ] everyone tags and no one gives
me tag it's actually what it is it's a
compliment to you right that they think
I don't need I give you tax no no I
don't mean you I just you mean like yeah
like I yelled this at Chappelle one time
in 15 years ago
I don't have a Neil so [ __ ] yeah help
me yeah but you know what though when
you get into a dynamic with someone like
that who's just like a super strong
personality yeah like the denying it
there was a hierarchy of course that he
wanted to keep you know that just
happens like that you know even when you
hang out like when I before I got on
workaholics I was hanging out a lot with
Craig Robinson uh-huh you know he was on
the office and it was his thing so we
had this thing where he was asking ya
pick him up from the airport it [ __ ]
like that you know that's super cool
because we he lives right down the
street yeah you know so we just were
friends like that but it was 60 bucks
you know what it was this is how Hillary
she say that because I asked him to pick
me up in the airport you know what he
did
he sent a car right visible for uber and
all that you know so it's like so I get
that he had a thing where it was like
he's Craig Robinson and I'm nobody you
know and even if I don't do like I give
Fahim opens for me I give him tags all
the time yeah you just say but you're
you have a writers directors mind you
know you're trying to fix this you just
that's just how you you know that's how
you operate and I just think that I
think more of a show operate like
there's Karl I realized when I was going
to NYU film school in 1991 like I went
moved to new your comedian Kevin Brennan
so in high school I used to go to visit
New York and visit the club which I grew
up Philly Philly okay so I would hang
out with open mic Dave Attell open mic
my brother and a open mic mic Roy here's
another comic another guy Dave Jessica
who were my brother's friends Romano
before like in 1990 1990 I moved to New
York for film school and realized when I
was in film school and I was working the
door to comedy clubs we're gonna tour
the Boston Comedy Club which near nyeo
near the cellar and the regular weekday
show would be Chapelle a tell Louie
Marin John Stewart Jesus all of them
unknown right and I was like these guys
I like these guys any more than I like
these film students and I also realize
going to film school unless no one's
gonna let me direct them unless I write
it so I was like let me just be figure
out how to be a screenwriter and joke
writer and that so from that point of
view
by the way Edie Solomon who wrote all
the Bill & Ted movies a bunch of did the
same thing used to go to the store and
give people tags there's a few guys like
that that just go and help guys like hey
I'm not a comedian but and so I did that
for you know until I started doing
stand-up like so you started stand-up
pretty late yeah well you decided that
hey I think I could do this too yeah it
was just more a matter of I didn't I
felt because I was doorman I was like I
this I'm not one of these hungry
performers with their need for attention
That's not me so and then realize how
much attention you actually I did and
then eventually I was like alright and
then one Chappelle show explode like
imploded exploded that imploded I was
like well I need to figure out a way to
have a career yeah but other than I
didn't want to write for like what yeah
but to say it wasn't fulfilling enough
huh for TV I'm not gonna write for other
people yeah like I'll write on like
one-off so I'll write for Ellen or rock
or when Seth hosts the show
right some but but like I'm not gonna I
don't want to sit in a room right right
I was doing a show that I was gonna be
on and I would it was one fun quit this
is not how I want to spend my life I
remember I said she once when somebody
was asking me somebody that I know
there's like connected with Mel Brooks
wanted to do this Mel Brooks thing and
they mentioned your name and I said I
just casually said it to you like I
don't want to be in the business I don't
want to be I don't want being like you
want me to do a show about me I'll do
that but but you want me to help
somebody that I'm funnier than ya what
for money I I don't need money I don't
need the money I'll direct commercials
so it's all about so then so you are
you're a little pretentious about the
art then you wanted to I know now I
pretentious or selected I'm just not
gonna if you don't want to do a role are
you pretentious right right well I'm a
it depends if the reason if your reason
is like I'm above this role
all right there's a Pizza Hut commercial
that they want you to go to drive to
Burbank and put your in and know I feel
yours before there was one time that I
was at a commercial cuz normally when I
would go to commercial auditions I my
tip was always whatever find out what
the joke is
play on that right there's a joke and
yeah play on that have fun
and so I normally just go and I had a
great time I was booking commercials it
was fun but there was one time I went
and I was like oh this is dumb it was
like target and you had to sing like a
right so that you call that pretentious
yeah yeah it was I was like it's both
yes okay
or if I'm pretentious yes I under the
pretense that there are hierarchies two
qualities of work boom so I think we've
seen to somebody no pretentious is a
negative yeah you definitely it comes
across as negative but sometimes say
sometimes I am pretentious so I know
sometime I'm not you just have standards
yeah what 10 just means the picture like
you're wearing an ascot and a wearing a
beret like no I just don't want to
[ __ ] spend my life doing that yeah
yeah but everyone is makes you feel so
you're supposed to be so great
all the time right that did not want to
do this target commercial you're
pretentious like I can agree with fire
and wasting my time on a garbage thing
yeah I can agree with that I mean I
that's why I feel like no matter what
level you're at once you start doing
whatever work you're gonna find yourself
in that work being like I don't like
certain things like when I was doing
workaholics is great okay but like there
was parts of workaholics where I was
like oh really I'm doing another you
know dumb scene where I got it like you
know somebody's hitting me or somebody
saying some things to me I come in
nonsense nonsense nonsense and then
leave yeah it was a party it was like
okay I could do more you know yeah you
know that's what I was talking about
this like Kyle you know Kyle knew to
check hee hee hee like after I did the
first season of I'm dying up here he
hits me up but he's like yo man you've
really grown as a performer and I was
like bro no I haven't got I was like bro
you know we were doing the shows at the
same time yeah like I didn't stop for 10
years go to acting school and then like
now I'm an actor no you just got you
guys weren't using me yeah you know so
there was a part of me that and it's
weird because people that are not on a
show they might be like but you should
just be grateful you should be happy
you're on a show that's like you need to
get on a show and then you'll understand
you know yeah it's not it's not the
pretentious thing too is you ever not do
a joke even though it works yes like I
don't want to do that joke I know yes I
uh and that's why again circling back
that's why I Adam said to me do your a
stuff tonight cuz it was like cuz
sometimes you know we go to the comic
strip and we're working on [ __ ] right
you know it's like cuz we don't have
open mics anymore are open mics like
Wednesday night yeah and then it but
then it's like this store is so jumpin
sometimes it's like [ __ ] I can't even do
my I gotta go do a show yeah cuz it's
packed and all the rooms are full yeah
so where do I get to like work my [ __ ]
that's you just have taste it's like
yeah you know Chris Rock always yells at
me 80% of talent is taste and and it's
like yet you've got to know it's all it
all mean people take cues whether they
mean to or not
so they people in show biz go
like there are people that that get
defensive and go like like Sebastian is
a great example right so I used to bang
the drum for Sebastian I was like this
guy I'm telling you it ten years ago I
was gonna do a sitcom with him and my
agents for like who the [ __ ] is this guy
and because showbiz is so snobby they
didn't he was never on like he was never
in the cool crowd right and and then
Scorsese was like this [ __ ] guy's
funny I was like you know who's good
like he did a concert the other night at
the Forum and it was like the weekend
was there yeah and John Legend and Chris
John and Chrissy been friends with it as
long as I have so but there was like a
lot of people like snobs DiCaprio went
like real snobs that are now like oh
this guy's great yeah and I don't think
they were against him before that I
think they didn't know him but I know
people who they didn't like his pants he
would wear a vest ons he just has
Midwestern fashion tastes and that's a
thing that people like you just gotta
know the what the everything is a game
yeah and like what am i signal into
people yeah so like I am pretentious in
that I have my own aesthetics I'm not
doing it for other people I just like
don't want to dress like a dork Ryan I
know that if you wear a certain kind of
pant certain people will think more of
you and and people that are again I know
you you're gonna go on and want to play
that again no no I wasn't gonna say that
at all I'm that's that's not that's not
it at all man no I'm just saying like
that's just part of like that's the
that's like when you go when you get
into the shakaama D you think like all
you gotta be is funny when you first
start it yeah you know if that's what
you that's just this with an actual
really stupid thought is to think that
all you need to do be is funny yeah cuz
if that were the case I can put this
there's funny people you know everywhere
it there is a lot of truth to it but
it's not funny is a big tent so yeah it
comes down that I we say the the way I
judge comedians is the most
obviously original thoughts it's like
when Lauren Michaels cast Sandler and
rock on SNL they rock us like we came in
like 5th and 6th at the audition like
people kill way harder than us and he
asked Lauren why'd you hire us and
Lauren was like original thought that's
that's why so original thoughts and if
you do sort of tried-and-true areas how
high is the level of difficulty how high
structurally what have you done with
this joke what are you saying you say
even if it's a you know even if it's
like a relationship joke yeah is it is
it a unique relationship joke and also
structurally what did you do yeah what
do you wanna do that added to comedy
it's like the best Chappelle's Show
sketch is Rick James it also happens to
be the highest level of difficulty which
people probably don't realize it's a
[ __ ] documentary about Rick and
Charlie fighting so it's structurally
it's bananas and it happens to be really
funny so if you can figure out a way to
do really good comedy it's bill burr and
Louie and rock and Chapelle and Mulaney
and all these people like they are
operating at a very high level and and
there's tons of the people I'm
forgetting like Sara Wanda
Sebastian Shoom like there's tons I
could go on and on but they're doing
they have taste in terms of what how
they approach comedy yeah it's not just
like it is a lot of jokes that they will
not do like I'm not gonna do that job
right I thought of it I think a joke you
ever think about joking like yeah it's
ten years ago yeah but I find it like
the Internet makes things like hacky
like really fast yeah good you know
something happens and then like you have
this thought and then you go online and
you see like you know rock and Mullaney
have the internet - yeah everywhere
everybody you know it's like all
everybody has the same thought so you go
away from that yeah you know and that's
but Mulaney had horse in a hospital
about Trump and it's the best Trump joke
there is and it's a
[ __ ] Trump joke that he did two years
ago right right and before that he had
the previous winner of the best Trump
joke which is he looks like a poor man's
idea of a rich man and it [ __ ] would
murder and he was you know he's a Conan
set from 2006 where he does a joke and
it does great but it's like Trump's a
guy from The Apprentice so it's you take
into a consideration that there are all
these venues and outlets and you're
seeing it to me as like well the rule
the internet I'm gonna like no no that's
not what I'm running faster again I
don't think you understand me what I'm
saying
yeah I think because I I'm agreeing with
you I think you're coming at me like I'm
not agreeing with you or I'm saying
something that I'm not no what I'm
saying is the Internet has to make us
more thoughtful so like you're making an
example of being like you know you ever
not want to do a joke and what I'm
saying is the internet helps with that
oh yeah that's what I'm yeah okay I
thought you were saying no no no I'm
saying the internet helps with that like
because something burnt means so many
times I burnt later with your
persecution complex I assumed it was
flaring it this is what I've said I
think that you I think has you're
misjudged I think you were missing money
I'll take that too you know I mean so
yeah no I I feel like I like all this
stuff like me too and and all the things
that have happened is only making comics
work harder and I think that that's
great yeah it's like well they do it's
it it's like a gymnastics routine or I
figure skating routine it's like there
are the compulsory bits that like
everyone's probably gonna having me to
bit like I mean not directly but it
direct it was pretty it was the biggest
story in the country right and involved
people we knew yeah so like when people
like all these helmets don't mean to
[ __ ] you not gonna do me two things or
there's something not around it but you
better be [ __ ] good yeah yeah yes
everybody you know I mean it's it was
worse a year ago but every at the store
everyone had it every comic would bring
it up and so you just better hope yours
is good yeah hope it's authentic and
original like you're saying
that's like you know that's and that
comes down to tape that comes down to
pretense it comes down to why is how is
the Irishman different than Goodfellas
because the the people can't discern or
how is Mulaney different than Chappelle
or how is Mulaney different than Sara or
how like can you differentiate people
can you can you analyze art and know why
one thing's better than another thing
yeah and because I think there are
people comics going I'm not pretentious
and I don't pay attention that I'm just
regular it's like well that's why you're
a [ __ ] hack yeah yeah yeah yeah
because you pretend that you don't care
and you may not but it's blaze eNOS it's
not because you you are intimidated by
the cool kids well that's what I'm
saying that I think that when these
things happen to in society like like
you know I feel like you know people are
like a big feeling is right now they're
everybody's too sensitive like young
people are too sensitive and I'm fine
with it I'm fine with everybody being
sensitive I'm fine with us having to be
more thoughtful about how we talk about
women on stage and how we're all these
things because it's just bringing better
jokes out I would say and I haven't seen
your act probably in a month but I don't
get that idea watching you is that you
are fine with it because that's not you
don't have any jokes about being fine
with it yeah but no no but what I'm
trying to say is the jokes don't have to
be about being fine with it
just like it's like the jokes just have
to be bulletproof like your jokes have
to be like if you have an opinion about
something right you can't say it in a
way that people will be able to be like
oh you're a misogynist or you or
whatever right you she's still like if
you want to talk about women and I think
that they're 50% of the population and
they are hilarious so if you want to
talk about them you can't just do it in
the same way that it was that it was
before you have to find a way to do it
in a way that people can still find the
humor I would suggest Joey better on
you would be I do know what you mean and
I think I would suggest if I were your
coach I would include that in your set
up meaning cuz I don't you on stage
you're like man these [ __ ] [ __ ] ass
right but that's not true if do you
believe that or not no I I know what I'm
saying is this is not original going
like every I mean it's like everyone's
joke is like these kid I mean it's
literally that's 70 euro it's the old I
know Jimmy well I know what you're
saying so that's what I'm saying it's
like you know you just ever-evolving you
know I like to I like to come see I have
to step back for myself a lot of times
you know but we do so many sets you know
yeah so it's like you know it's like
okay you know there's some times you're
in a mood like I find myself I know when
I'm in a mood I know when I'm in a mood
and I go onstage and I'm like oh man I'm
too angry right now yeah you know I know
and I mean that in a zone like that yeah
you know so I'm like I don't like this
what am i doing yeah you know what I
mean then that's why I can't you know
the thing you were saying where it's you
used the fuel of rejection I just I just
seem mad if I'm on stage using rejection
of I'm at I need to I do better when I'm
upbeat about things yes and and I think
but I think a lot of that also has to do
with just how you look like you're
saying like you know you can't
absolutely you can't come across as like
you know cuz yeah even a little scratch
on my face yeah it's like you always
tripped me out you and Ian Edwards
I know if you guys name same person if
you guys like when you guys do act out
yeah like I'm always tickles me because
it's like it's like not necessarily in
your comfort zone right doesn't like
you're doing an actor but occasionally
when you do like one like yeah that joke
about the the whatever I think the vent
there's something about like the ATM
machine or something or I'll [ __ ]
that yeah yeah just when you do that I
just got ah that's so like you know but
it's [ __ ] real course yeah but that
actually works in my favor cuz you don't
think I'm gonna [ __ ] the stool that's
what I'm saying
yeah sort of say but you're also a
wordsmith well you're you're very
meticulous and a locksmith I'm kidding
like it has to like though the words
have to be said a certain way yeah and
you know it's like very much like your
baby
the the mic because of my face my jokes
have to be perfect yeah I honestly like
they just I learned that early I was
like alright well I can't kind of [ __ ]
this joke up but then but see I like
that but for me I'm just such a jolly
guy and a weird you know I got to my
comedies here that sometimes if I'm like
sitting on a certain type of attitude
the contrast makes people laugh or if
like you know when I'm like when I'm
upset about something and I'm talking
about it let me tell you what happened
at this thing yeah people laugh at me
because it's like I look at the jolly
guys up yet about something but this I
seem genuinely a cancer but you know
again like I say I'm trying to evolve
I'm trying to like I think that's what I
love about being at the Comedy Store
right now that's what I love about just
not even the comments or just doing
comedy in general you know just being
it's just like what I like about the
Comedy Store by the way is that you know
you got to stay relevant you know yeah
you know you got it if you want to be in
that core group of people you got to
keep it moving keep it you know keep
working keep working so I like to think
that I'm working but it's like I want to
go further you know what I mean with
everybody challenge myself like me you
know what I'm saying so use the tilt
skills and talents that I have
I would suggest other than if you're
asking I could tell you what I would
suggest let's hear it it's just more
sophistication in the point of view
right right right then you want to yes
like because it seems like you're one of
these like bei like [ __ ] you Amazon
lady in the wheelchair no I won't
[ __ ] help you like it seems like you
earned she's not a wheelchair what she
in it stunned doesn't even a thing but I
get with you yeah yeah you get like I'm
not [ __ ] up it's like there's a way
to do that joke about that where it
becomes about fairness
and it's about like no I signed up for
something yeah but that's how did I talk
about those things but I know what
you're saying right but there is a way
again you talk about it
the message I took from it was go [ __ ]
yourself
right it's like thinking about being
more precise about that's the word I'm
looking for
boom that's it that's the word right
there because I what what what I'm
saying is cuz what ends up happening for
me is like you know you get lost in like
how like you know entertaining how I do
things
you know it's entertaining but it
doesn't mean that I that's not all the
what I'm trying to do it for you know so
it's like yes
precision being precise but also what do
you say what water but that
interpretations of this right and how do
I sure up that people if not
misinterpret this idea right right right
and that's the that's the hard part for
me because it's like if my emotions if
my emotions are funny to people as
opposed to also wanting to be understood
that I am making this particular point
you know but I've had people come up to
me like I had a woman come up to me and
say like hey listen I work with disabled
people and I really appreciate how you
said that how you how you how you how
you were talking about it so it's like
it just depends yeah but there's
probably somebody who'd appreciate it
I'm like that's what I'm saying so it's
like but still it's got one or if you
wondered I don't wanna feel the depth
exactly exactly I feel like I am I feel
like my point is coming across but when
you're in an argument with someone you
know say offstage and I'm talking with
someone less um and they're not giving
me and we're in an argument that means
to me that oh then I they don't
understand my point that means that I
didn't express my point prop right you
know I never blamed it you know if
you're in a fight with somebody it's not
like you don't get it it's like uh-oh I
that's a very good that's a very good
way to think about the world but but
super Neil but that's how I think about
like when I when I feel like I say I
need enemies and all this kind of stuff
I never it's like I always I never I was
a type that goes it's not a bad crowd
it's me yeah you know you're way better
I mean long term that's how I always
think about like so so so like Tommy
didn't like me I was like alright well I
got a gift I gotta be funnier so this
guy goes I have to be undeniable for him
yeah for him to be like ok you gonna be
a paid regular
that's just how that's what I that's how
it fueled me yeah you know but then just
my wires were getting crossed where it
was becoming too much and then so to the
point where someone like yourself would
be like yo I have this impression of you
you seem like this kind of person I
don't like that right you know so then
it's like alright well what I want to do
is so you have to just decide because
then like you say there might be ten
people who are like oh man I think
you're great another person's like oh I
don't think you're great so now you have
to decide well where do I want to be on
this spectrum like where do I want to be
how do how I feel about it and that's
you know what we're working on now Mike
you want to hear my advice for myself
yeah get face surgery advice that would
be but see I actually had the thought oh
no you're so odd about people know you
now that they would know you got certain
oh but I'm gonna be a probably gonna do
stand-up at some point with one of those
clowns smiles cuz I think it'll act if I
go on with clown makeup it would make
them world I I'm just gonna do it one
night like do the nose not even the nose
just this just this money maybe some
like you know of Rouge but I want to go
onstage in clown makeup in clown makeup
well not and not clown anything not
creepy clown makeup just like all
clogged up is great yeah I know it is I
don't know if clown makeup is gonna fix
you my cereal my setup face is so
serious that if I if I'm straight and
then there's a smile will do well you'll
see I don't but do you think with like
the Joker out there and all these kind
of movies about crime now is practice I
don't do it this years if this awards
season Eric if I don't get it down it's
not gonna get done
oh man well this is a good solid hour
how did we do it out yeah great did good
solid hour look man you know it's what I
like about having people on the podcast
is like you know we don't get to really
delve into like talking with people but
I
I I think that I think we have a missed
I think we misunderstand each other
sometimes yeah you know I mean like a
mad no no no not at all but I'm seeing
I'm seeing that now and that's like
interesting to me so now you know it's
like with you with our friendship I want
to make sure that I'm making a better
effort to like be more clear about
whatever I'm saying how would I be age
that's honestly that's what I that's the
cuz I know you're thoughtful and then
you because you there are some ideas in
your act that are really [ __ ] new like
that's a very fresh angle and then that
are some that are a thousand years old
I know it's just and I'm like well do
you not I know you know the difference
because I know you're not [ __ ] stupid
but Zess in that you know what it is
about is like that's what told me like
that's when I was like I gotta get a
notebook I asked like now I'm using
things on my phone it's because that's
what I was saying about what I admired
earlier is like that's what the
difference is it's like I wasn't going
back and like really picking apart
things enough right cuz I was just was
relying or roud you can hear what they
think even in the left they we can
listen to a crowd and go listen more
thoughtful they like it women are women
manner here's the men chart up up up
Plateau women's quick up quick down yeah
they're just yeah but I'm saying on
certain joke so to me I go I got to
either stop doing that joke or I got to
rewrite that joke especially if it's our
relationship well I I'm gonna I'm gonna
delve into it more because sometimes by
the way sometimes I on purpose like to
see the up and down I like one of the
things I love is like I like saying
something into women and then really
like it and then say something right
yeah may come of it then they go cuz it
you see the emotional like yeah so
sometimes I'd let you a follow me it's
only good if it's worthwhile yeah
meaning like women you're smarter than
men right applause applause applause how
come you can't beat us at anything but
bang like that's a worthwhile trap to me
yeah just saying something that's not
you know bladow to me if they just serve
of court like for something that of
course they're gonna be four but if they
are [ __ ] yeah and then setting that
to me is a worthwhile trap yeah yeah
it's just like you know it's also they
like learning the difference between
like the words that you're saying the
point that you're making and the
performance that you're doing they have
to have a better relationship you know
because for me it's like sometimes I'm
going up I just hey I'm angry about
something and I and I know that that's
funny to people I've always known that
even before I was doing stand-up when I
was coaching you know I'm yelling at the
kids and the crowds laughing because
yeah things that I was saying how I was
so I knew a long time ago that like I'm
funny angry you know you know so it's
like alright I'm funny I take that
onstage irritated in a powerless way I'm
funny like I'm very funny like what like
a girl friend asked me one time what I
wanted for Christmas and I go just be
cool
that to me is I'm very tired and I'm
asking for very little please be cool
but for me it's like my my outrage level
however about even about something that
is like so small that I make a big deal
out of it I know that that's why people
are laugh right but what I'm saying is
it pick a better target yeah yeah yeah
yeah don't make it I don't you mean
don't make it these [ __ ] PC people
yeah right right right cuz you're not
white yeah I know you're not being
helped PC culture is helping you is
helping non-white people in the long run
even comedians it's like PC cultures
just don't be a [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
yeah just don't be don't call trans
transgender people [ __ ] is that such
a [ __ ] big deal
all right just be nice just be [ __ ]
not even nice just the bare minimum yeah
fair minute I don't I've never met any
african-american look man black people
are not having a great time out here I
like it do yourself a favor just [ __ ]
say african-american you know as I have
this thing I'm talking about right now
it's like if I wanted to go Muslim and
I'm like you know I want to change my
name from Erik Griffin to Shabazz
whatever just that [ __ ] hard so
that's what that's what I'm sure if
Muhammad Ali changed his name
if Cassius Clay changed his name now
they'd be like I know what and they did
they did it then but it's just place
that's what I'm saying for like the
transgender movement I'm saying like if
this person wants to be called whatever
it is physically assimilated that hard
hello you know whatever
yes that's like the thing I will say I'm
tired of acting like every day is their
birthday I'm all for equal rights and by
the way even if it is your birthday
[Music]
but yet that's the like all the things
that and that's our disagreement is I
know you know that yeah yeah and yet you
present yourself as like these [ __ ]
and I'm like you there's some times
right but when I sometimes on stage at
the comedy store when I see you yeah not
me but we don't watch each other all the
time
no but I know people that I've seen you
and go like that guy Eric seems like a
real like he really doesn't like women
right right right and I hate that right
and I that it's see that's what I'm
saying so when you when it comes across
a certain way it's like no it's just
like funny I don't know it's just it's
frustrating that's frustrating to me so
like I'm in this process right now I'm
being like let me put all this out in
front of me and be like how can I say
this differently get my same point
across and still and still be like you
know you know what's just empathy it's
empathy yeah I had two jokes about
women's periods one of them I'm like I'm
not gonna do that joke it's just a hacky
joke I have another one that is about
how women want to have kids in the the
basic idea is like women
because their bodies [ __ ] pester them
a quarter of the tent once a month the
body's like are we [ __ ] doing this
alright I made you an egg it's gonna be
very difficult to get rid of enjoy the
next four days yeah okay and then I sit
and then I liken it to if guys got
avocados delivered to them and whatever
I had another one that was like women
should tell us when they're if you go on
a date with a woman they should tell us
when they're on the periods beforehand
and and it would be like women imagine
if a guy said we can go on a date but
just so you know I have an ear infection
and can't hear a word use that it's good
yeah it's funny but it's kind of [ __ ]
misogynist oh [ __ ]
well it's a matter of what am i do want
am i it just sells it like women we just
want to [ __ ] you and you just want to
hear us talk it's like it's too
simplistic yeah yeah whereas I'm the
other one I'm choosing empathy yeah I
think what I used to do black jokes that
would be hit or miss until I started
saying my black friends cuz then it was
like oh he's on our side instead of like
you [ __ ] that's funny I did that it's
like nah just be a little empathetic
toward the group empathy yeah and see it
from their point of view for a second
cuz that's what white people what white
privilege is is not having empathy for
anybody yeah and not acting like how
does she mean like I had a I only had
one period joke and it's just I didn't
even know women I don't even know my
girl had a period until we we were
together you know I mean say cuz it's
like it seems as it seems as if the
period stuff only kicks in when you're
in a relationship right yeah cuz you
never yeah we used to [ __ ] during it
what happened or like what happened like
wow what we can't what do they change
the rules but even her whole attitude
and demeanor like when we were just
dating I never even knew you know cuz
she was fine all the time I'm like is
this was this an act like right
meet with this all from for show yeah
and now all of a sudden you're like a
monster right but that before even like
women are hormonal during their periods
like that's beneath you know that's what
I mean like it's just too simple I
wouldn't open my core do this then I
know maybe comes like but there are
certain things you become so hacky fast
it's like you know it's like airplane
jokes okay that's didn't that took 30
years no but it's like it's Khmer see
but another one is like medicine side
effect yep that's one like I don't want
to see it get it out of here medicine
side effects you know and so that's what
happens it's like these things that you
know they go they they come but then
like you know people still you want to
talk about relationships but like
relationships have been going on for a
thousand a year and they're be good yeah
and there are certain premises that are
like Louie was the first one to do plane
jokes at a high level where he was
talking about like people complaining
and and I remember him doing airplane to
expand like wow
Louie's doing an airplane joke and it
was like about your people complaining
it's like you're flying through the sky
like a Greek god like how are you
complaining so he was the first and then
berhad one I don't know if he ended up
keeping it but he was like should I do
an airplane to it like yeah these guys
are concerned yeah yeah yeah yeah at
least bill was I'm sure Louie was like
it's good enough but like just have a
[ __ ] code and a standard yeah yeah
yeah yeah I agree I agree yeah yeah this
is I hope you guys got a lot out of this
conversation I'm going for I certainly
do free consultation with a with a with
a plastic surgeon well I appreciate it I
mean I wish that we were were able to
have better conversations offstage
before this point you guys you're making
it sound like we were like no no I'm
saying I wish it no no but no dude you
know how it is like it's like you know
we're all sort of egomaniacs we're all
sort of like you know it's like it's
it's it you don't want to go up to
somebody and be like yo I think that
this is good I can't come up to your
premises they're beneath you yeah yeah
yeah it's like this is you know we don't
we don't have a relationship with that
you know so you know that's a tough
thing to tell anyway that's from saying
yeah so it's like you know you want to
be able to don't get
wrong I do it all the time yeah you have
a way but that's why when you come out
of nowhere and say that to somebody
people might be like that guy's a smug
[ __ ] yeah you know but you're just
like hey no I just you know i'm a i-i-i
don't I really am trying to help I give
you tags I'll give you yeah yeah
Chappelle one time said to me I can't
wait till you stop doing that joke that
was his way I can't wait till you stop
doing that he'll say Dane Cook I had a
joke while I was doing one time at Dane
Cook he said to me he was like don't do
that joke anymore every time we do it I
go yeah it was just a ballet what was
that Pacific Rim they were that movie
Pacific Rim so like they're fighting the
whole time and then at the end there the
major fight the big robot pulls out a
sword and you know I was like open with
the sword yeah it's like but this is how
I look at it you know he and he didn't
like it like that I was like open with
the sword
it didn't work it was killed you know
but it's like we don't meet but what I'm
saying is I know I was it were you doing
it for too long go ahead well I wonder
why he didn't like it I don't know why
he didn't like it but my point is I
appreciated that he felt I'll tell your
relationship with Mia that he would come
to me and be like hey man uh you know
I'm like that so I appreciate that we
had that kind of relationship because
honestly I'm open to that type of
criticism it's like you said some things
to me on this podcast and if maybe kind
of go I don't know if I agree or I do
agree or out that hurts but it's like I
think that that's how you get better you
know I mean so it's like I can give you
Chris Rock it said the meanest like
literally you'd quit anyone else would
quit the joke that Chappelle told me he
couldn't wait til I stopped doing I did
this joke so [ __ ] long ago but it was
like with all the technology we have
Photoshop and makeup and Auto facetune
if you're still ugly in a picture you
have no one to blame but yourself I
think he was saying it
you don't want to call [ __ ] ugly
people ugly right right like it's just
kind of like ah he's a [ __ ] master by
the way of like call the people call it
but they don't know it yeah yeah yeah
but yeah like I don't you know I hope I
haven't been harsh on you like I we were
talking about it so yeah no no I'm just
saying but you know well but that's what
it's gonna come with you know it's like
if you you know there there's a lot of
people trying to do comedy there's a lot
of people at the Comedy Store even just
a Comedy Store that are trying to do
comedy that you know may or may not
achieve a level that that they thought
themselves to me yeah and it's just for
a lot of reasons it's just work ethic
it's you know not really intellectual
like because use what you do we are
intellectualizing stand-up comedy we are
looking at it and talking about this is
why this works is why this does it even
the using a word like empathy is
something that like you if you unpack it
properly you really can look at all the
things that you say and do and why it
works or doesn't work you know and it's
like a lot of people I don't think even
or thoughtful like that about it so I
always made the joke with Chapelle where
remember his joke about aids coming from
a monkey all right and he's like he's
like no one [ __ ] monkeys and people
like you either [ __ ] monkeys or you [ __ ]
people and I was like you're the only
person in the world who would take the
side of the monkeys in that snare
because his whole point was don't put
this on monkey for primates yeah yeah
that's like that's the the like I have
like jokes where I'm on the side of
Mexicans or on the side of Muslims
around the side of like how the [ __ ] all
they do is work like how do you not
that's the different that's why there's
not very many Republican comics it's
because there's not any empathy in the
Republican Party there's that's their
pitiless they're like work harder it's
your fault
[ __ ] you work
harder you if you can't afford health
care it's cuz you didn't work hard
enough meanwhile there's people who work
80 hours a week and can't afford health
care so what I'm saying is if you have
empathy in when you're setting jokes up
first of all it gives you more latitude
because you can say stuff because you've
established I feel this way yeah and I'm
not being mean to yes yeah this is why
I'm saying this yeah like I'm saying
just the whole point of the set up the
handicap thing could be or whatever the
woman who can help whatever that
whatever the drug was like I why did I
pay for this is not fair to me
yeah which is the whole point of it
right that's lost though yeah to some
people but I understand you're saying
but if it's I'm analytic it's lost on me
yes not like I didn't think that's
possibly what you meant yeah but if it's
open to that much interpretation yeah
it's got a you have to you have to
tinker with the setup tinker and you can
hear it in the laughs you could change
the setup and hear the laughs you'll
hear the laughs will be I promise you
the laughs will be bigger yeah I know
what you're saying
so yes hard it's like when you're you
know you
I don't you me because like right now
like I I'm talking about my mom's
dementia so it's like you know which is
great because it's like personal and I
immediately know what where you're
coming from
yeah yeah yeah so that's what and I know
that's why that's why I'm trying to say
to you is like I understand what you
mean yeah so it's like but to see to see
the hard part I cuz like I'm already
stepping out from I stepping out of
myself right now as we're talking about
this because I know how as a comic maybe
ten years ago I would have been like you
don't hear these people laughing because
like I could get people like like the
night that Ted was there I was doing my
that particular joke and this
[ __ ] crying and like barely
over the belly laughing so I'm like I
know that this I can get that kind of
response from people but that's not an
that I know that that's not all right
yeah it's like you still cuz cuz people
can still laugh at something and then in
their mind I go uh-huh
I really laughed at that but that still
was really [ __ ]
yeah I mean but there's it but you know
it's easier to go back in the past but
like shucky ducky got laughs - yeah you
know or gallagher or whatever it's like
gallagher had good joke like Gallagher
doesn't convert it for having actually
like good he'd like good verbal
dexterity jokes but anyone get a lot of
people get laughing that's where talent
becomes tastes like yeah do I want to do
that that joke or that joke and am I
willing to [ __ ] throw that joke away
yeah yeah I would say don't fall in love
with material yeah I think I find my
seconds nowadays again I think it
because of social media because of
everything it's like I just don't fall
in love with jokes I just you know I you
know and you know like I said I agree
with you on the empathy that's one way
to look at it I mean it's like you know
exciting you got a guy like Ricky Ricky
Gervais who like doesn't you know I
don't know if he I don't know if empathy
would be something that he would he
thinks about first you know uh yeah I
mean are you thinking about his Golden
Globes thing or you think just in
general I've seen a bunch of his stuff
and I don't he's a piece Ricky Gervais
is saying one thing and being another
petty he's just a petty [ __ ]
like it's likewise arguing people on
Twitter on it and you said this and I
did it it's like you you're penny he's
not he's not really on the side of
humanity
he's on Ricky said yeah well there you
go he would suggest he's not empathetic
at all right that's what I'm saying
but at night but at the same time still
being someone that like you know you
know you look at like like what happened
to go the gloves I I was tickled by that
what was happening there but this isn't
exempt both examples of what we're
saying because I don't know if he had he
didn't necessarily had to do it like
that but then it the effect that he got
from it was the effect that he wanted
you know it was very much very biting
very you know in your face it was just
and I there's a part of me that was like
I love how that made everybody sign it
didn't make that didn't really make
people comfortable that's what I don't
understand did it did I think that
people in that room are uncomfortable I
think that the head of Apple was
uncomfortable oh yeah you know I think
that when he called
the actors mostly most of you are dumb
and and like stop coming up here with
your speeches I think he made people
uncomfortable you know I think like I
don't think that to me is like a pretty
obvious point no I know but but the the
Apple thing did he mention Netflix in
that no I mean I also use Apple Amazon D
is the they're the righteous multi
national corporation yeah when you give
somebody 40 million dollars they're
right but Netflix polled Hassan's thing
about Saudi Arabia
cuz the Kingdom asked like but Ricky's
on that it's like you're a [ __ ]
hypocrite dude yeah yeah yeah that's
what I'm saying it's also like how big
of a hypocrite of only being in this
joke
that's another night like it's hard I
always find that I think it's hard to
always call myself a self-hating liberal
because once you become a liberal you
start making some money if you're making
money it's hard you know it's hard to
like connect with blue-collar because
the things we're talking about you know
it's like you live in a gated community
but you do you if I live in a gated
community how can I talk about the wall
if I you know we're talking about body
positivity with trainers and like in
money to eat well all the time and it's
like it's a it's a weird thing so you
have to write I've been doing a bunch of
bits about that like Chappelle was like
dude that's the [ __ ] best angle is
like I'm I'm a bad I liberal it's the
way yeah yeah but if I look in so
liberal I love that like it's it stop
yeah that's what I'm saying it's it's
but very different saying if you are
more thoughtful and more considerate of
your own experience you will come to
that premise before me yeah you know man
like like you could do that that's a
thing that you'd like take stock of your
life
yeah for sure um I used to I know what
you mean man this is very for people out
there want to be communist because a lot
of people hate me out why I want to be a
comic I watched your podcast no I want
to do you know cuz I just want a podcast
episode called how to be a comic you
know right so it's like you know this is
very like really analyze the things that
we're saying right now analyze the
things that you're saying I mean yeah
like me I've been around
[ __ ] for 30 years yeah yeah yeah yeah so
I think stop for real I've been around
the [ __ ] and succeeded at it watch
people succeed like I know what the [ __ ]
I'm talking whether you think of an
[ __ ] or not fine right right like I
know what I'm talking about and I've
seen so many people succeed from nothing
to become yeah you know that's the
beauty of this just sometimes people are
just one great special away out one
thing away from just being like you know
even though they were like already had
like I look like that's like Ally I love
watching her thing you know I always
funny I'll Ben I'll always been funny
you know been a writer performer for a
long time just going going going going
going and then had that thing to just
wow you know yeah she just finally had a
man help her and get her pregnant Rock
is a good example of I mean his career
was over and he had it me and Judd
Apatow talked about this one time Chris
Rock had a joke about Martin Luther King
that was so [ __ ] good in like 1988
and and and and and then Judd goes and
we both came to a conclusion and then he
wrote an entire act of jokes that were
that good and the premise was so [ __ ]
sophisticated it was Martin Luther King
Halle is a holiday is Martin Luther King
Day is a national holiday including for
prisoners right so the guy James Earl
Ray who assassinated Martin Luther King
gets the day off and he probably goes
around prison reminding people like you
know I'm the only reason we got the day
off
1989 like [ __ ] love you want to know
what level of sophistication where
you're like you're not thinking about I
had a dream none of the top level [ __ ]
yeah it's like here's a premise Ian
Edwards to me is the best at that of
like we what what yeah where'd you come
up to you get there yeah all like think
about his comedy
EML hyperemesis I'm like he pitched me a
premise the other day that's so [ __ ]
funny and like it might be too
complicated for me to do which is like
so [ __ ] it I'm like I dude I totally get
it
it's so complicated I don't even think I
can do it he's another guy that what I
love about yams we're really great
friends so when he comes off stage I got
tags for him yeah when I come on stage
he's good he's what he what I love about
him is he'll say to me like you just
need to work on this one thing because
that sounds like something yeah you know
selling soda yeah he'll be he's good
about that then he'll say like but other
than that you're good yeah so I like
this I just feel sometimes I feel like
we just need more of that at the store I
feel like there's a good him I mean I'm
just not a part of it you are I'm not a
part of it so I'm trying to ingratiate
myself more to be like I want to be a
part of that I want people to for why
about people giving you tags or just
like gives em tags yeah just being
helpful like that you know I'm very much
like Leslie Jeselnik is a guy that like
he go take attack yell now I sent him
one and he sent me a he does it take so
he's the kind of guy that's like with
Giancarlo was around he was like that
you know he wouldn't take people and I'm
like okay I thought his reasoning was
more of an ego thing purely you know but
like you Jeff Fenech is just like my
thought process is like he has his way
of head works
fur doesn't either yeah Birds not I get
yeah you know to me Bastian does I've
given instance yeah yeah yeah yeah he'll
he'll listen to him yeah me too so I'm
saying like there's certain dis review
but it's like I just not I don't know
you know what I mean
no I gotta I gotta like you know make
people feel like hey you know what what
do you think about this and so I had to
be open to for somebody to say to me
like what you said to me some other I'd
be like you know I like that one joke
but it sounds like this and I wish you
wouldn't do it like that or or you you
know you have to open yourself up to for
people to let them people know that like
oh no no I'm willing I want to I want to
make it even better I want to make it
great you know yeah that's that's the
admit what's missing because we walk
around there and we're so like you know
and I'm a big demonstrative personality
so I can see people being like I don't
think that guy wants to be told anything
you know what I mean so I got a like I
don't I don't know
I feel like I use it so I don't know you
or don't know I don't know what your
experience is like with everybody else
but yeah I don't know yeah I don't have
a I don't have that sort of open
experience but everybody yes but but
with you it's just because of how you
are yeah so I don't know I'll give tax
tip [ __ ] over mic yeah yeah yeah if I
honestly like I don't suppose you just
like to listen to I love one like what I
love is when some like clearly open mic
or door guy or somebody that's just like
they're not there yet but they might
come up to me and be like yo man I got
this thing I just go right let me hear
what you got you know what I mean oh
yeah oh you ever know somebody like if
you would Jim yes when you're doing also
if you use it it's thrilling oh yeah oh
yeah I remember it yeah it's really
telling for him gave me a tag the other
day that I've been using and I'm like oh
I just love it like it you know and I
love using it and then I go to I love
telling him I'm using it yo that [ __ ] is
working real good you know so yeah I
just I just like that feeling so I want
more of that as what I'm saying
sorry can't always know after this
podcast it's gonna be alright
I know anyways I want to thank Neil
Brenner for coming on the show yeah all
those information will be down here and
I'll see you guys next week